[Music]
oh yeah I'm the king of
Atlantis true king bill Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges during King ATL's time there
were Seven Kingdoms and the Trident was
a curse upon them
all the trident's dark magic is
spreading he means to end the bloodline
two of you standing together
Brothers promise me you will protect
each
other
run I don't know what lies ahead but we
can't leave our children a world without
[Music]
hope you know I got a bunch of King
to do back
go
oh yeah I'm the king of
Atlantis
true king builds
Bridges the trion's dark magic is
spreading he means to end the
bloodline we can't leave our children a
world without
hope